i'm sure i've had some white friends who
have been disowned but
coming in the religiously in the sikh
religion there's nothing against
um homosexuals but the culture is such
uh for hindus and sikhs i think for
muslims it's even harder
but i think culturally especially in the
uk because a lot of the immigrants
that came from india were from um
non-educated village backgrounds
so they didn't they came to this country
saw the western way of life and kind of
shunned away from it
and they protected their children very
much so i've lived in india and in india
the middle
class elite and educated gay friends of
mine are all
out and most of them if not all are
accepted so here we have different
cultural issues
which the government is neither
addressing nor any of the community
members or the religious
houses no one's kind of like just left
as it is so there's many cases of um
suicide marriages of convenience
happening and
um many guys who just end up marrying
women for the sake of it
and carry on you know people that have
done that that you know are gay but have
decided to marry
i know countless people who get
most cases i don't think any of the
wives know no and you said
picture and he said that basically he
couldn't even talk about it
so um when i i've done a tv series for
the sikh channel and it didn't um
on different topics the homosexuality
one didn't air on tv because it was too
controversial but it's on youtube
but i did it in the language of punjabi
so that people who are from those
backgrounds could have literature
so i've also done a punjab radio show
about it but um what
you know we have bbc asian network and
they talk about all these issues in
english
but nothing for those like my parents
speak very little english and those
communities
who are immigrants so we need to have
literature in that vernacular
um i mean i'm a founding member of the
birmingham black minority ethnic group
lgbt lesbian gay bisexual transgendered
but the only thing we're limited to do
is cultural events we do get lottery
funds but
there's nothing being done in my
community itself i tried to look for
self-help for parents
but it was only for english speaking
mainly white families
but do you feel that attitudes are
gradually changing
um from what i see and i have people
phoning me because i do life coaching
and spiritual workshops and
counseling and all sorts of things i
mean i'm writing a book called bollywood
gay at the moment which is about all the
issues that people have to confront it's
a self-help book but from my opinion
people are phoning me and saying to me
that they're married to women and they
don't know what to do they have to keep
their
they call it is that which is like the
dignity of the family and so
uh in my opinion i don't think it's
changing i think
the gay um middle class population india
is actually ahead
of the the indians that are here and uh
we're a generation behind i think it's
almost like a lost
generation this generation of gay and
lesbian
youth will end up getting married to
someone of the opposite sex
and perhaps it will be their children
after so we're kind of losing a
generation
to this and something needs to be done
about it